you might have noticed that Nickelback
was trending after President Trump
tweeted out that meme words Nickelback
the song photograph and then they hold
it up and everybody puts a different
thing in the picture frame well he used
it as a way to attack former Vice
President Joe Biden yes so Twitter has
since taken down the video so when you
go to trump's account all you see now
are the words that say look at this
photograph with a message saying this
media has been disabled in response to a
report by the copyright owner
yeah people on twitter seem to be happy
that the video got taken down with
writing sorry Fred delicious wrote this
okay is there anything more pathetic
than violating copyright law with a
pinned Nickelback tweets
yeah Nick Jack papas tweeted when you're
so awful that even Nickelback hates you
Oh burn but not everyone is happy Kristy
Swanson is not impressed and she's not
happy with Nickelback to themselves
throat hey Nickelback this is such a
bunch of bull that you would disable the
media on this I bought your song on
iTunes 9 hours ago because I love to
trump's tweet so much and I've also
always been a fan of you guys now I want
to return the song and get mod nickels
Buffy hi I and I know that movie got a
lot of hate but it's one of my favorite
movies of all time original original the
best in that oh great I love I wish she
did more I think she does hallmark
movies oh yeah well she does a lot of
this she's very big Trump's you did yeah
I'd like if you're if you're a huge like
Buffy fan and stuff maybe don't dig too
too deep into Kristy Swanson Twitter
feed I want to know your reaction cuz I
know you tweeted out about this last
night because when everybody first of
all whenever I see anything trending I'm
like oh my god this something happened
to Nickelback yeah I mean I know that
there's hate but they're Canadian band
you know I support her what was your
reaction to this I thought it was
hysterical I was laughing I showed
everyone of my family I was giggling my
face off I thought was hysterical
because one I love that mean right I
love it
my favorite meme of all the Nickelback
photograph memes is the one where they
edited out photo and then in the picture
frame is an actual graph and it's just
look at this graph
that's my favorite of all the Nickelback
memes that's awesome I'm a bit of a
loser cuz I didn't even realize this is
a thing Oh meme I was like no it's his
song yeah I didn't realize that oh
people put up everything sure Zinn in
that picture frame they put everything
in that everything you can imagine has
been in that picture frame yeah
okay so Jodie saying I love Nickelback
and I agree with them because some
people are like was it Nickelback who
took it down was it
ya know who took it down I don't know if
we know for sure but we just know that
it was taken down for copyright issues I
know is saying just delete Trump's
Twitter once and for all and we'd have
nothing well hold on here I'll tell you
this and not that I think that his
tweets are you know anything that are
worth anything but if you delete Trump's
Twitter if you can delete the Twitter of
the most powerful person in the world
think of what they can do to yours
that's actually very true
Harry sink Chris is irrelevant I don't
care what she wants
oh there you go and Skippy saying I
thought it was funny that's Nickelback
was trending I did too I thought that
was great I loved it then I loved that
nickelback got thrown into this
everything about it was just great it's
so good and I loved it the tweet is
still there like every knows everything
about it was just awesome I checked he's
still trending so I was thinking like oh
great maybe this song will hit the you
know the charts of i.t would you would
also be amazing and that'd be quits it
would be really happy for them